all right guys our next guest
legitimately earned her place on the
world stage she is the most decorated
gymnast of all time an American Hero
please welcome the goat Samo B hey look
at that hey s hello so you had a big
comeback in 2023 let's get into it uh I
just want to say it's so good to see you
back how does it feel competing again it
feels surreal I didn't think after Tokyo
Olympics I would actually be competing
again so this year I just took each day
as a blessing and I ended up competing
so I couldn't ask for more you have five
gymnastics moves named after you right
so do you have a favorite move and and
can you still do all five of the moves
that's funny I can actually still do
four out of the five oh snap okay like
one of them is too hard that I can't
even do it anymore um but we're working
on it we're working on it so I don't
really have a favorite I guess there's
scary to most scary but which one is the
scariest the scariest I think is my uh
vials 2 on vault which I just competed
in Belgium um in October yeah know what
that is I would have said that you know
exctly I would said the bows two uh that
that that's what I would have came out
the gate with you know Ken I don't even
know if you noticed about me but I did a
little gymnastics did you yeah so from
age what to uh how old was I oh my God I
think I was I think I was
I I think I was probably 12 yeah I
probably got 12 I was a late bloomer but
I had a lot of success Simone I only had
two moves named after me one of them one
of them was called the get the back
get get the back off off this
that's that's a flip the back flip they
say when I flip anybody can get kicked
in the mouth you understand me so get
the back is what you need got get
your ass back I'm coming in hot and then
number two was number two well number
two I'm not going to get into number two
cuz number two got banned it got banned
completely one of the only moves never
get banned yeah congrats by the way on
your marriage this is big I want to talk
to you about the bachelorette party what
was the good stuff lots of tequila lot
of boat days I mean we had a blast I
think the craziest part was like I
sliced my foot open on the golf cart
like going to one of the bars you ain't
supposed to do that and I was like oh
that looks deep but like we're just
gonna have to keep moving because
there's not real like Hospital on the
island that we're at okay so um you just
gotta bleed to death you gotta let this
bleed out take a chance yeah take a
chance my husband's family was there
they they got me right so we just kept
it pushing that's crazy though she did a
bachelorette party in the same radius as
the husband's family and her mother
that's a everybody went together party
yeah you know we did mine underground
yeah was that off the
radar went deep with it yeah we went
real
deep now your your husband is in the NFL
right yes who do you think is the better
athlete in the house I think we're good
at our own sports we've tried to pin
each other against um on like difficulty
ability and all of that stuff so at the
end of the day gymnastics is harder if
he agrees or not wow yeah that's a
that's a nice politician answer but here
here's the truth I'm not trying to stir
anything up in that house I know your
name you know what I'm saying that's all
I'm going to say I know your name you
know what I'm saying so let's go back
let's go back to what you just said
which is that uh gymnastics is much
harder sounds like this has been a
household fight for some time you want
to get into it now maybe we clear it up
we fought over it a couple times and
then we we vowed once we got married we
wouldn't talk about it again but it
keeps coming up every time but uh he has
done my workout in the gym and he could
barely do it and then I went to their
and L A lot of shot fired shots fired
she's doing a lot of it's a lot of
uppercuts being thrown with you you know
what I mean I guess the other big
question on everybody's Minds is will we
see you in Paris good question I know
everybody keeps asking this question you
feel free to answer or not but we want
you to answer um that's the end goal and
I'll be there regardless of if I'm on
the floor or if I'm in the stands do you
want to compete or do you want to just
you know be a legend I hope I'm on the
floor you're already a legend day I just
do my gymnastics and then the committee
selects the team so got it you want me
to call somebody cuz yes I don't know if
you know this but Kevin's a big deal in
gymnastics so I'm a big deal he can make
it happen for you all you got to do is
go to my website Kevin har gymnastics.
org.net do do do back the up back
the up flip that's what it is
Simone thank you so much for the time we
knew that you would stick to land in
here